and finally new rules stop acting so
surprised that Trump thinks he's God's
gift to America because that's exactly
what Evangelic illipe telling him he is
last weekend conservatives had their big
annual convention which featured such
speakers as Glenn Beck Devin Nunez judge
Jeanine Pirro and of course Trump
himself it was a virtual Woodstock of
the mentally impaired one speaker Mike
Lyndell the my pillow guy said this I
see the greatest president in history of
course he is he was chosen by God yeah
Mike's pillows are made from foam but
his head is stuffed with feathers but
but Mike's belief there is not unique a
significant portion of our population
believes that in 2016 God put Donald
Trump in office and I was giving all the
credit to Putin and if you watch the 700
club regularly like I do you know that
Evangelic Azhar now making the claim
that Trump is a modern-day version of
King Cyrus King Cyrus he's kinky
yes Kings in the Bible okay why Cyrus
well because of angelical needed to
solve this little problem they had which
is if they want to support the
Republican president but this particular
one happens to be the least Christian
person ever a man who loves flesh
peddling coveting cursing cheating
bullying bragging sloth and ultry and
ripping off charities a new lies more
frequently than the rest of us P the
type of man who would go into a
confessional booth and never come out
[Applause]
how to square that circle just say Trump
is like King Cyrus Trump has the Cyrus
anointing God was raising him up like
Cyrus they're calling our president
Donald Trump they're calling him Cyrus
Donald Trump is a Cyrus gets it
president Trump will be like Cyrus
Donald Trump is like a modern-day Cyrus
yes I I know what you're saying to
yourselves bill who the [ __ ] is Cyrus
I'm gonna tell you Cyrus is the ancient
king of Persia who conquered Babylon
where the Jews were living in captivity
this is before Miami now Cyrus didn't do
it for the Jews he did it for Persia his
country but it had the happy side effect
of allowing the Jews to return home to
Israel so Cyrus you see is an unwitting
conduit a a vessel for God's will accept
Trump
it's an investable for God's will he's a
vessel for fried chicken and the and the
analogy on which the whole thing rests
is [ __ ]
for one thing Cyrus wasn't a fat orange
conscious with scumbag he just was he
just wasn't Jewish but nothing in the
Bible says he was the antithesis of what
the Jews believed in the way Trump is
the antithesis of what Christians are
supposed to believe Cyrus wasn't a
notorious sinner he wasn't a
pathological liar he didn't call scribes
the enemy of the people he never paid a
concubine hush money
and Cyrus wasn't the leader of the Jews
if Trump equals Cyrus he would have to
be a foreign leader who unwittingly
helps America we're the Jews in this
analogy but they don't care you see that
that's religion for you the more it
doesn't make sense the better because it
proves your faith so when the name cyrus
comes up amongst Christians they all not
approvingly that they're down with the
code like when potheads here for 20 you
know they also get this believe it's
significant that the chapter in the
Bible that mentioned Cyrus is Isaiah 45
and Trump is the 45th president you
can't argue with science people
to be frank I don't believe anyone even
checks biblical passages anymore you say
a biblical sounding phrase with a couple
of numbers after it and religious nuts
will crochet it and hang it up in the
kitchen
[Applause]
so Syrus it's just more evidence that
the Bible will always be used as a
justifier for whatever you want Jeff
Sessions used Romans 13 to justify the
child snatching at the border senator
Kevin Cramer used Thessalonians to argue
for throwing families off food stamps
because it says if a man will not work
he shall not eat senator inhofe uses
genesis to deny climate change because
that's where it says as long as the
earth remains there will be springtime
it just starts in January now
[Music]
you almost have to respect their focus
they decide what they want and they work
backwards to find a few phrases in the
Bible to justify it
a secular types we don't have that
luxury we see Trump colluding we can't
point to Isaiah 45 all we have is us
code two three eight one the part that
says whoever gives aid and comfort to
the enemy is guilty of Treece
you